vamos a aprender acerca de lo que son
las matrices y que después lo que quiero
decir cuando habla acerca de matrices
bueno matrices en realidad es el plural
para la palabra matriz que probablemente
ya es una palabra muy familiarizada
sobre todo por hollywood más que por las
matemáticas pero bueno que es una matriz
bueno realmente es una idea bastante
simple simplemente es una tabla de
números eso es todo lo que es una matriz
por lo tanto permítanme dibujar una
matriz para ustedes déjenme cambiar este
color porque no me gusta este color
pasta de dientes mejor uno amarillo
entonces voy a elegir algunos números
aleatorios no sé 5 12 3 0 menos 5 ok
esto esto es una matriz todo esto es una
tabla un arreglo de números a menudo si
quieren tener una variable para la
matriz lo pueden poner con una letra
mayúscula digamos vamos a llamarle a en
algunos libros lo ponen como una letra
en negritas entonces y bueno esto es un
poquito de notación por lo tanto esto es
lo que llamamos una matriz
lo que llamaríamos solo por convención
una matriz de dos por tres porque ya
veces escribimos este dos por tres por
debajo de la letra
y esto lo que representa en realidad el
2 representa el número de filas por
ejemplo aquí tenemos unas 2 filas y el 3
lo que nos da es el número de columnas
ahí están 3 verdad entonces esto es una
matriz de 2 por 3 cuando decimos no sé
ya saben he dicho si yo dijera que ve
déjenme ponerlo en negrita que es una
matriz de 5 por 2 lo que significa es
que b tiene 5 columnas 12 de 0 menos 5 y
10 ahí están 5 perdón son 5 horas porque
entonces tiene 5 filas y necesitamos
otra columna vamos a poner menos 10 37
2 y sale muy bien
esto es una matriz de 5 por 2 por lo
tanto creo que ahora tendríamos una
especie de convención verdad que la
matriz es una tabla de números podemos
representar esto con una letra mayúscula
que probablemente se escribe en negritas
y podemos hacer referencia a los
términos de la matriz verdad por ejemplo
si yo quiero referenciar
este elemento de esta matriz
entonces este es el elemento de la
segunda fila y de la segunda columna
verdad entonces este es uno y dos uno y
dos muy bien entonces está en la segunda
fila y en la segunda columna entonces
así lo pondría la gente
y vamos a poner que está en la fila 2 y
en la columna 2 22 va a ser igual a 0
ok o podría escribir a veces puede
escribirlo con minúscula el elemento a
22 es igual a 0
si solo esto es notación por ejemplo a
ver quién es
vamos a hablar de la misma cosa
simplemente estoy poniendo esto para
poder manejar notación entonces digamos
que tienes a 13 eso significa una cosa
que estamos en la primera fila y luego
nos vamos a la tercera columna y por lo
tanto esto es 2 ok
todo esto es notación de lo que es una
matriz recordemos una tabla de números
podemos representar sus distintos
elementos de este modo así que te
estarás preguntando bueno esto está muy
bonito es una tabla de números
fantástica está la notación bien pero
para qué me sirve y ese es el punto
interesante una matriz es solo una
representación de datos es sólo una
forma de escribirlos eso es lo que es es
una tabla de números sin embargo se
puede utilizar para representar un
conjunto muy grande de fenómenos por
ejemplo si estás haciendo esto en tu
clase de álgebra álgebra lineal
probablemente lo utilices pero más tarde
aprenderemos qué y de hecho voy a
hacerte una serie de vídeos sobre la
aplicación de las matrices a un montón
de cosas pero esto puede representar
bueno esto es muy poderoso es puede
representar los gráficos de computadora
estas matrices los elementos pueden
representar puntos en el espacio pueden
representar quien sabe hay toneladas de
cosas que pueden representar por lo
importante lo importante es que no es no
es este un fenómeno natural no es como
muchos de los conceptos matemáticos que
hemos estado mirando es una forma de
representar un concepto matemático o
representar valores pero tienes que
definir lo que está representando pero
bueno vamos a poner eso en un segundo
plano vamos a
eso es en términos de lo que representa
y está aquí mi esposa está buscando un
fichero pero bueno de vuelta a lo que
estábamos haciendo
esto permite representar ciertas cosas
ciertos datos porque creo que al menos
inicialmente la parte difícil es como
sumo matriz como multiplico matrices
como encontramos determinantes de
matrices sé que todas esas palabras
pueden parecer extrañas ahorita y quizás
este esto te esté confundiendo pero voy
a enseñarte punto por punto qué es lo
que vamos a hacer y luego más tarde voy
a hacer un montón de vídeos sobre la
intuición detrás de ellos ok y lo que
representan por lo tanto vamos a empezar
a trabajar así que digamos que yo quiero
añadir o sumar más bien estas dos
matrices vamos a decir digamos que la
primera es
vamos a hacerlas un poquito chiquitas
para no gastar espacio esta es la 3 - 1
las dos
y 0 y esto es igual vamos a llamarlo a
la matriz a digamos que la matriz ve que
sólo estoy inventando números no es
ningún ejercicio particular pero este va
a ser menos 7 2 y 3 y 3 y 5
ok entonces mi pregunta es qué significa
o qué es
la matriz
y así que estoy poniendo en negrita como
lo hacen en los libros de texto y si se
la sumamos a la matriz b ok vamos a
sumar dos matrices se trata de una
convención que nosotros estamos creando
ok a lo mejor alguien podrá definir otra
forma de sumarlas pero esta es nuestra
convención y esto es útil para un
conjunto de fenómenos por lo tanto
cuando se agregan dos matrices vamos a
sumar los elementos correspondientes así
que como su como como cómo funciona esto
así que agregamos el primer elemento de
la primera columna con él con la primera
fila de ambas entonces esto es 3 más
menos 7 ahora sumamos el elemento de la
primera fila y la segunda columna de
ambas y entonces tenemos menos 1 + 2
está entre paréntesis para que quede más
claro de qué estamos haciendo y
separemos los elementos verdad y
podremos al eliminar qué es esto después
sumamos dos más tres que son los
correspondientes a la segunda fila y la
primera columna y finalmente 0 + 5 que
corresponde a la segunda fila y a la
segunda columna verdad de ambas matrices
y esto simplemente nos queda en el
primer elemento es 3 menos 7 es menos 4
aquí es menos 1 + 2 que es 12 13 5 y 0 5
es 5 y ahí lo tenemos así es como los
seres humanos seres humanos perdón hemos
definido la adición la suma de matrices
y por esta definición se puede observar
que esto va a ser lo mismo además a
verdad y esto es algo que tenemos que
pensar porque ya no estamos agregando
números o que ya sabemos que 2 es igual
a 2 es uno más uno o digamos que dos más
uno es tres y uno más dos también
no importa si hacemos
podemos conmutar los sumandos y aquí por
ejemplo en la suma de matrices podemos
hacer exactamente lo mismo
verdad porque estamos sumando el
elemento por elemento se puede imaginar
la la resta de matrices es esencialmente
lo mismo verdad por ejemplo quesería
a la matriz a menos la matriz b bueno
también podemos ver es de mayúscula y
está en negritas esto es una matriz pero
lo que estoy haciendo es simplemente a
más o menos uno por b
ok que es menos siete por dos tres y
cinco verdad y entonces cuando
multiplicamos un escalar cuando
multiplicamos un número por una matriz
en realidad es multiplicar esa matriz o
cada elemento de esa matriz por el
escalar en este caso es menos 1 x menos
7 aquí tendríamos 7 menos 2 - 3 y menos
y -5 ajá y a continuación esto sabemos
lo que es
esto será obra la suma es 10 verdades 3
+ 7 y ahora tenemos menos uno menos dos
es menos 32 menos 3 es menos 100 menos 5
es menos 5
y no tienes que ir a través de este
ejercicio aquí este podrías tener
literalmente solo la resta de los
elementos verdad y habríamos llegado a
lo mismo lo hice porque quería mostrar
también lo que significa multiplicar una
matriz por un escalar y simplemente es
ir multiplicando cada uno de los
elementos de esa matriz por el número y
bueno por esta definición de matriz de
suma que es lo que sabemos ahora bien
sabemos que ambas matrices tienen que
ser del mismo tamaño por esta definición
digamos por ejemplo podemos añadir estas
dos matrices podría ordenar la 123456789
a esta matriz digamos la menos 10 menos
100 2012 1 0 0 1 0 1
ok podemos sumar estas dos matrices
verdad porque tienen el mismo número de
filas y el mismo número de columnas así
por ejemplo si si deseamos sumarlos el
primer término será menos 10 + 1 que es
menos 9 acá será menos 99 2003 sería
hablaban en fin no creo que entienden el
punto y tiene exactamente 9 elementos ok
y bueno si yo no tuviera las mismas el
mismo número de entradas
de otro color
la menos 32 y la matriz no se es
97 ok
aquí porque no podemos sumarlas ok bueno
no tienen elementos correspondientes
para sumar verdad esto es una fila por
dos columnas y esto es una columna y dos
filas así que no tienen las mismas
dimensiones por lo tanto no podemos
sumar o restar estas matrices y como
nota aparte cuando una matriz tiene
cuando tiene cuando su dimensión es 1
digamos en realidad esto es a lo que le
llamamos un vector fila o que hay un
vector es esencialmente una matriz
unidimensional en alguna de sus de sus
características ya sea de fila o columna
por ejemplo el de la derecha es un
vector columna verdad así que si toman
álgebra lineal o cálculo y el profesor
utiliza estos términos sería bueno estar
familiarizado con ellos de todos modos
estoy empujando me de más de dos minutos
que debería nos vemos